all right gonna do Oh before now you
ready the special surprise for you oh my
god no movies tonight this was a joke
hope because we got there secured my
guest don't stare and whisper cousin
community is pretty [ __ ] up off of a
sentence cup Kirko courtship and get it
okay what is up Alexandra hockey Tuesday
I wanted to thank you for being a Fame
and clicking for the excited to read my
book your husband dania resist me and he
wanted to get you my book as a surprise
gift and then rush me to say that he was
worried you might either gold by
yourself before he eat with you or that
you might discover on your joint amazon
account that i think bought a few 150 /
45 so he mentioned that your big thing i
really appreciate that that he is also
paid but we were much more of a fan so
the other work on Daniel gives me more
of a panicked when Daniel brother school
or what watching videos but you know I
don't know that it's more just to
Alexandra but but one does need my
sister so that's pretty cool and two I
doing you have a pretty special person
who really cares about you and bulls the
extra mile is
they think so I admire that I'm an angel
crazy though I hope I hope you're having
a great night whenever I you know this
is locked in for me so it's an insane
day and just wanted to make sure that I
got this video for you and the next with
special thank you and as part of the
price yet so that's it thank you for
your your loyalty and all the opnet I
believe in you hope you continue to baby
when yourself hey whatever everyone word
is enjoy the foot much love about these
it and Bucca rise tomorrow but I got
your kindle edition thank you so much
you have no idea how much this means to
me thank you so much for greedy my
amazing husband oh I'm so so happy
speechless have your book ready when I
start reading it tonight and I should we
copyright the world oh wait for one ah
you changed my life you live at all like
my everyday will paint my head assembly
like I am so grateful for you and thank
you for putting this slick awesomely
awesome lets the littlest for everybody
ten people show me how much you care for
a friend oh just I asked to some amazing
in few things and I love I know I'm
going to see you I released you i'm
going to tell you all about it and sweet
thank you so much thank you for being
you good luck with your book in the
directory do they have to need a little
boy and I'm going to continue to believe
i'm going to share the love with
everybody around me thank you